good morning believe nation today's
message is you have to be great over you
dave grohl if you're good at what you do
people will recognize that I really
believe it I really believe that going
out and playing good songs live as a
great live band will make you successful
I'd really think it will and it doesn't
matter if you're at the [ __ ] hold down
the street or you're on the side stage
at Bonnaroo or you're headlining well uh
Palooza if you're a great band with
great songs people will notice it that's
it that's all it is it's that simple
product placement and labels and ANR
people and all apples it doesn't matter
I swear to god it doesn't matter and if
you back that up with the idea that just
playing those great songs in your great
live band is enough reward for you then
you're set but you've got to be badass
you just have to be really good it's the
other things that make up for your
musical inability you know I mean as a
drummer I never felt like I'm gonna be
on the cover of Modern Drummer magazine
because I'm the best drummer in the
world I just do that if you put me on
stage without a PA or floor monitors in
a small club that I would beat the [ __ ]
out of my drums so much that people go
goddamn did you see that drummer whoa
and I'd walk away from every show like
there you go I just beat the piss out of
those things that people saw it people
took notice for sure and that was great
so at the end of the show I was a
successful musician because I had
what I wanted to achieve so I honestly
believe I mean I know lots of musicians
that went down to South by Southwest and
said well it's easy for you to say I'll
make it man I was in the same position
you are in 24 years ago that was it I
worked in a Furniture Warehouse and I
wanted people to like my music so I
played out as much as I could you know
and if you really honestly I'd like I
said if you're passionate and driven and
focused in what you do if you're really
good at it people will take notice
that's basically it I mean I don't
understand the industry I don't
understand I don't understand where
music is headed I don't really
understand technology I just know that
when you walk into a club and you see a
band that blows you away
you are gonna follow that band you're
gonna either buy their CD or you're
gonna find them online or you're gonna
see them the next time they come to play
and it takes that's what it takes you
don't have to stand in line at the song
contest on TV to become a popular
musician you know to stand in front of
some judge that doesn't even play an
instrument on their own goddamn records
tell you know you're not gonna know you
know go blow people away in front in
their face and so it's gonna you know
it's it's I honestly believe it's that
simple I love this message because it's
simple but it's hard it's simple advice
and makes sense but it's hard to do it's
hard to accomplish because to actually
be great at something you got to put in
insane number of hours it's a little bit
disappointing to hear because it makes
you realize that maybe the work that
you're doing isn't great enough yet
right like maybe the work that you're
putting out people just don't care
enough about yet like maybe it's just
not good enough maybe you need to
practice more maybe you need to get
better and that sucks because it's a
long road where I would much rather
prefer and I'm sure you would too that
you know you swallow this blue pill and
you're successful right where we want
the hacks we want the shortcuts we want
the path
we want the easy way and there are
things that might make it easier but at
the end of the day your stuff has to
work I've told this perform that on the
channel for me it comes back almost
every quarter I go through this this
thought process where like what can I do
to market videos better like I'm really
happy where I'm at Natalie we've got
400,000 subscribers but I feel with the
message and the content and the impact
that we're having on the current
subscribers that I should be at four
million like this is only a small
fraction of where I feel like I should
be right now and so I think okay well
how do i market it better who do I
connect with how do I get it out on
Twitter more on Facebook more and in my
email news that are more and how do I
get people talking about it more right
you just focus only on the marketing
side of things and what it always comes
back down to is I need to make the
videos better because as good as they
are they're not good enough yet and my
very first videos when they first came
out some people love them right now I
had a really small and core audience and
some of you have stuck around through
some early years with me those videos
were okay they were pretty good but
they're not as good as they are now and
so now I'm able to reach a wider
audience because my videos got better
and for me to be at the 4 million mark
until the 400,000 mark my viewers have
to be even better
so it's not so much about how do i
market them better how do I get more
exposure for them better it's never been
easier to spread a good message where
it's never been easier to share
something that you like if you watch a
video and you really like it you might
just give it a thumbs up but if you
really loved it like it touched your
soul you're gonna share it right you're
gonna send it to some friends you're
gonna post it to your Twitter account
and tell people about it you're gonna
tell your best friend who's going
through that issue and say you have to
watch this video and the reality is for
most of my videos the reality the hard
truth for me to swallow is that they're
good but they're not at the level where
you guys are watching them and saying I
need to share this video because it
moved me so much and that sucks
and suction week and I'm putting a lot
of work but it's still not good enough
yet like I'm getting what I deserve I
met 400,000 subs because that's what I
deserved
where if I make better stuff you guys
will share it more it will lift
naturally and I'll get to where I want
to be and so looking at your business if
you're unhappy with where you are now
don't just think about the marketing
don't just think of how the promote it
better take a good hard look in the
mirror and ask yourself is the part of
the service that you're creating so good
that when people have an experience with
you they can't wait to go out and tell
people about it because if you create
something at that level it's gonna
spread it so the question they today is
I'm curious for you guys what is missing
what is not great yet in your business
what do you need to work on so that you
can create that remarkable product or
service what's missing leave in the
comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion and finally one think of a
quick shout out to Frederic moon our
from the Giant edge Fredrik thank you so
much you're picking up a copy of my book
it really means a lot to me for those of
you watching you want a chance at a
shadow in the future video make sure to
grab a copy of the book and email in
your receipt so we can keep track thank
you guys so much for watching I hope you
have an amazing day continue to believe
or whatever you're one where it is and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso